I don't know how many cases of wine did
you buy nothing like listen listen it's
money but here's what's cool about it
you're gonna [ __ ] give it to climate
you like it's so smart you got your
prospective happy happy this is the biz
dev barter of empathy wine episode is so
I bought giant and all he was doing was
postcards it was called giant clothes
cars 2011 arrived at company yeah so
how'd he come up with the name of the
company go ahead so he he had one thing
right he was doing shared and this is
where I have to if we want to debate a
little bit please debate with you
because that plan right there so he had
a plan I took it and I perfected it to
that so now the manager of the club if
you flip it over say that's called sham
any time finis whatever that manager
right there goes next door to anywhere
from two or one really the New York the
New York Jets were paying me millions of
dollars and making millions of dollars
by putting a logo in the bottom
left-hand corner of the video and
picture we posted on Facebook shared is
not exclusive to postcards or social
media if you're gonna tell me what you
are that they amortize down the cost I'm
like cool you can do that on Facebook
and you can do it at scale that's true
and you can run more arbitrage on
Facebook because if you know how a
mailbox the post office is fixed
Facebook is broken it's a marketplace
you get to take advantage I am picking
up fans in who speak Arabic for 1.9
cents right now fans not consumption
follows I'm gonna get paid two hundred
fifty thousand dollars four hundred
thousand dollars of speech in in Kuwait
and Jordan and Dubai in a year because
what Facebook does that the post office
doesn't is it doesn't floor it
this is your right I understand what
you've done that's really right yeah
that's what science spaces can do I
totally got it look honestly you'll
appreciate us looks like literally just
like like you know what's funny
it it I don't hate direct mail I just
know if you use Facebook perfectly with
the mentality of direct mail it's scary
I don't also say to you bro this is the
same to everybody
I can literally put [ __ ] sushi on it
for him it's crazy but but much like
you've perfected this this practice of
Direct Mail has been around for 80 years
there's so much work to be done on the
content side on Facebook and on the
discipline of being great at spending
eighty eight dollars against African
American males that live in you know
downtown Atlanta who loved the Hawks but
not the Braves I mean the [ __ ] is
[ __ ] in gnarly and there aren't
agencies yet or humans that really
understand what a Plinko board of that
level looks like like I said I you know
to me like yes and I got to deal with
that market be honest yeah so I correct
yeah I've been around for eight years
but like it's different
exactly no offense I'm pumped about yeah
yeah so I didn't know I preached these
twenty four year olds patience I lived
there I don't want to be a hypocrite I'm
pumped that I [ __ ] ate [ __ ] or grind
it and I was doing great like you like
like this this is why I'm over reacting
to your 37 or whatever you just like
you're gonna have more ups and downs
depending on your personality trait you
know like ups and downs are based on
risk when you come from the dirt yeah
you have more losses because you're
[ __ ] playing with like you don't
forgive [ __ ] when you start doing a
write a little bit it depends up my dad
hit a place where he was like [ __ ] it
I'm good
yeah so I'm not gonna put myself in a
position ever again to you know and
honestly I'm kind of that way too I've
enough of a nest egg in the thing and
even building garyvee is really built on
what if all [ __ ] goes to [ __ ] and so I
always talk about the truth the economy
being vulnerable this to that nature
because when the economy collapses I'm
gonna be right cuz I'm right and two I'm
not gonna get 150 I'm gonna get 30,000
but I'll still get 30,000 you know and
at least I get like that's like my
insurance policy anyway so you pivoted
and what you were super narrowed to just
this world
no no just right now for James to or
just direct any buddy
but that client was big the rig that was
that was just it was disruptive that my
talk there because they were so big of a
percentage of morons got it if it was 8%
I wouldn't matter if you were Kentucky
Fried chicken's and you don't want to
fight you didn't wanna you don't want to
fight the like you're smart you could
have not only that you would have had to
[ __ ] fight the inevitable fact that
over time the internet will continue to
gobble up more you're gonna have to
fight harder on lower bargain for a
smaller pie I love that you did that
super impressed with it
anyway good I got into literally so we
still do the direct mail because it's
still it's still good it's probably 40%
of our business so now as you know Gary
Mel's expensive right now on our revenue
it's good I got it I get it
so I two and a half years ago I said
okay we got into everything not
necessarily everything works mall so we
store with banners then we win stuff
lanyards then one wins t-shirts t-shirts
really took off t-shirts is I think
that's awesome I think where it's gonna
be and now we literally if you go to my
site we've literally you make I don't I
hate to say no like somebody calls me up
hey can you do uh-huh
dancers yes brother I'm a believer I can
find it I'm at my best when I'm that and
I hate the years where my companies get
big and I have to let it be in the know
business for a little while and that's
what I'm just getting out of in Vayner
like last three years I haven't been
outrageously happy with the no culture
of my own company but what you do at
times is you start I'm a big believer in
yes and then I think there's times where
you're marinating some of those yeses
which forces you to do a little no and
and I hate those periods I'm getting
back into yes which excites me so is
there anything I can help with right now
absolutely what I'm don't get it twisted
okay
I don't it's the same reason I love
LinkedIn I'm talking a lot about
LinkedIn but I don't love LinkedIn ads
cuz there's a floor
I don't like floors I like Internet has
unlimited scale and inefficiencies when
you start at zero I'm a byproduct of my
reality I built a business from 3 to 60
million dollars in 4 seconds with no
money cuz Google didn't have a [ __ ]
floor at 5 cents a click and nobody on
earth at the time and I [ __ ] up I
should have built a trillion dollar
company but I was in my little wine
world nobody was buying silver oak and
red wine and Bordeaux and [ __ ] clean
house and that's why I love social media
Instagram stories right now
we'll sign up a lot more people to the
gym than that if you know what you're
doing it's like anything else like if
you're good at baseball
then it's a great idea you make [ __ ]
23 million dollars here being a middle
reliever but if you're not you're not
like so it comes down to skill I
actually like paper
I like real world I like events I just
talked about it I like paper because
there's a place for paper I write books
in your form people make fun of me
sometimes like Oh mr. digital like
because people read them there are very
few things I [ __ ] on that I still do I'm
doing direct mail this week
I don't know so tell you well that's
probably a better question yeah right
that's the bigger you always start with
the moon and work but yeah exactly I
don't I don't even want to know how much
paper is being printed in America
exactly so I guess the question is what
do you have right when you say we hat
we're gonna do everything are you
sitting in the middle and outsourcing do
you have a printing press like what the
flattery is no what's my time is by how
much I know by how much
okay we go 5 moments awesome so this why
this barter thing I'm doing is stupid
because I'm not gonna be able to stay
like we've spent all this time analyzing
my time then it's so expensive that we
kind of discounted I'm already upset
then I'm gonna go over by 30 percent at
every meeting because I get pumped this
way I keep telling people like when I
have to sell something is the nut like
I'm impossible to get to and then I have
some
right and now you bought I don't know
how many cases of wine did you buy
nothing like listen listen it's money
but here's what's cool about it you're
gonna [ __ ] give it to climb like
you're nothing like it's so smart
I laugh I'm like having the conversation
with you guys like this [ __ ] sucker
like I feel like I'm not choking I feel
like a sucker but I love it it's back to
the grind of the game I love when both
people win
I love if you're winning and here's why
this I know to be honest I know that and
who's gonna and who's gonna buy what's
right and who's gonna buy wine people
gonna buy wine that can who's gonna be
at the barter they're gonna be able to
afford it which means they're in
business which means or like one person
just bought 100 cases they're donating
to charity the charity that I'm on the
board up is gonna use it at very high
events where it's gonna get good
branding so like totally and and here's
why good with that versus other things
it's truly a forty dollar wine leave for
20 bucks so the people that get it are
gonna like freak of how good it is and
if you give it to somebody who normally
buys eight to twenty dollar wine they're
to me like this is so good when they go
to the website and see it's 20 bucks buy
the case they're like [ __ ] this is way
better than what I'm buying at Total
Wine and it's because it actually is a
forty dollar wine for twenty bucks
anyway nonetheless what can we do here's
what I would say you're catching me at
an amazing time I'm as you know okay
here's what we can do let me give you
the whole game yeah I don't know what
Vayner is in a position where it's so
disproportionately pumped to get the
paper or direct mail business for our
clients because we're competing at the
highest level you know they're working
what's like you know we are but the
fight to the fight to get give me their
business when they're working with who
the [ __ ] knows at the scale probably
they're getting it at it and they're
probably getting added value from their
national media but like I don't know but
I'll do some homework the most extreme
and I don't think this is gonna like
intuitively this doesn't feel right
there's more almost doing it for him and
I I want Phil and we're going through
our own processes me really taking time
to sell Phil on this
good idea I'm desperate to create a
company called 49 I have this thought
that I'm gonna build enormous amounts of
wealth by creating a company that truly
partners with people that are actually
smart ha I mean think about it you paid
a lot of money to buy out a minority
partner me rolling in right now being
like give me 49% of your business it's
not like the thing that's gonna get you
excited so Phil's gonna put you on a
call
I want him onyx I wanted to learn you
should take the business from the guy
that's got it from us at Wine Library
so that should happen I think that's
good because I want to continue to I'm
testing the waters I still like it we do
both okay I'll be honest with you what's
really fascinating to me is the Mac I
think I can do it very weird
I'm in such a unique spot as a human so
cool this is the model I think Wine
Library could probably make five hundred
thousand dollars a year because unlike
all these companies if I actually have a
b-side if I do one video on Facebook
that says hey I'm doing something with
direct mail yeah I need you to send me
the samples your products because I will
not let you buy space unless I believe
in your product or service after we do
quality control I could probably be
mailing weekly and making my dad 5,000
to 10,000 have you know as a profit
Center that's what a profit Center is
that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying yeah wonder if we
can turn that into a business for
influencers so like thank you right so
think about what I'm talking about now
we test this with these guys we do it
for six months really get it down get
feel good about it we build out some
sort of little sales crme kind of little
thing that becomes scalable and then you
convince so for example Fitness
influencers like like it could be a
profit Center for influencers
penetrating demos they're not reaching
you know if you're the cliche app
good-looking dude or hot chick you don't
like you're welcome in look I love your
haircut - I'm super into you like I was
like [ __ ] man I wish I had that you like
his haircut I like that
tap to school but the haircuts good man
I haven't looked like it's like good
very good anyway so so I need to wrap
I'll rap here's what I would say through
the process you'll send me mail to them
me and Brandon Phil and bran will be on
the phone with you tomorrow you should
take that business we should do this
we'll do it once just normal make sure
everything that I'm sure that's not what
I'm worried about just it's the holidays
in January I think I'm gonna literally
I'm not joking I'm gonna try to roll I'm
gonna just try it I like I like saying
yes trying [ __ ] I'm gonna try to
subsidize it for my dad I'm trying to
find ways to help my dad make more money
I'm gonna subsidize it with like local
New Jersey I'll do I'll run the ads only
in Jersey it will literally be like Gary
B's jersey business recommended yeah I'm
like it really is something that I think
if you think about how I'm leveraging
brand is something my dad could be
making 10,000 bucks if my dad if I told
my dad dad good news you're mailing
weekly cuz it works it's just expensive
your mailing weekly and you're gonna
make $10,000 a month because I'm whoring
myself out on the other side through a
process that I feel good about because I
do like that restaurant in Red Hook and
I do feel good about the taffy place in
Atlantic City and I do feel good about
the you know whatever he'll be happy and
the business will grow he'll make
120,000 dollars in net profit just cuz
and his business will get a ton more
trap like it will work not to the thing
you know and then so anyway and then
maybe we build that much and then if I
like that probably this time next year I
would then be able to say hey let's do
this for real whether it's 20% like
we're really trying to figure out what
we're building
we've gone from investing the private
equity to direct the consumer brands to
a holding company but I think
and it does have to be filled by the way
if he decides not to pass on it I'll
it'll be an TK or Tyler [ __ ] Orsini
I think I'm inevitably going down a path
of a company called 49 Vayner 49 it's
smart or something about that like the
amount of people that like the turks and
caicos weekend every year on the 49th
week of the year i love [ __ ] like that
that's December December it's cold I
love that that's what right before
that's literally December 12 I love it
that's exactly right like you know the
entrepreneurial you know of America or
whatever those [ __ ] things to call
those they're outdated all those things
a holding company they're like and I can
really do it like I can like it's it's
what happens when you build brand in the
same way that you [ __ ] how to deal
with the ramifications of me getting
excited on stage and hockey arena in New
York I really really do think after I
got to know you where I wouldn't give up
my brand because that's what you're
scared of like I say you're [ __ ]
direct-mail dude I don't know you
I like everything so far into does it
feels right I like the story you do a
little homework you do something for a
year and you can say you're the direct
millions [ __ ] it's game over you'll
pick up an enormous market share you're
gonna do two million that's already way
better than one no yes yes a hundred
thousand all right now
[Music]